[Music]
hello everyone I'm Alicia Malone welcome
to the very first episode of fandango's
indie movie guide each week I'll be
giving you my picks about what to watch
in theaters at home which movies are the
most buzzed-about at film festivals and
what to look out for [ __ ] awards season I
promise I will tell it to you straight
and in true indie spirit I am hosting
editing producing writing and shooting
this show myself this week I'm at the
Toronto International Film Festival
which is one of the biggest and best
film festivals of the year it's right
here that lots of that award season buzz
gets created so I thought I'd give you a
list of the 5 best movies I've seen here
at TIFF let's start with my favorite
Manchester by the sea this is a film
you'll definitely hear about come award
season hopefully for Casey Affleck he
really deserves Best Actor for this he
plays a man battling with demons from
his past he is forced to face those
demons when his brother dies and he has
to take guardianship over his nephew I
think the idea was that you would
relocate relocate to Whitwell if you dig
it was my impression that you'd spent a
lot of time here I'm just a backup
nobody can appreciate what you've been
through and if you really feel you can't
take this on me that's your right I
don't want to spoil exactly what
happened to him in the past because
director Kenneth Lonnegan allows the
audience to piece things together slowly
and when you finally put all the pieces
of that jigsaw puzzle together it will
be like an emotional hit to your heart
it floored me this movie KC is excellent
also Michelle Williams is brilliant too
moonlight is a lovely film directed by
Barry Jenkins it tells the story of a
young man called sharone who lives in
Miami and the story is told in three
parts one when he's a boy one when he's
a teenager and one when he's an older
man
Tyrone has a lot to deal with including
a crack addict mother played by Naomi
Harris and also his own battle with his
sexuality
this Tahoma huh to you it's very subtle
very gently told and it all feels like
kind of a meditation on masculinity
definitely look out for moonlight
arrival is an intelligent sci-fi by
directed to me Villeneuve he's the same
guy that did prisoners and Sicario but
this one feels completely different it
stars Amy Adams as a linguistics
professor who is charged with speaking
with aliens when they arrive at 12
different places on earth and jeremy
renner is the scientist who's working
next to her
not everyone is wired for what you're
about to do it's where they look like
you'll see soon enough
every 18 hours this movie does not go
where you might expect it does have a
little bit of Spielberg feel it's a
little bit of Kubrick but a lot more
Christopher Nolan and Terrence Malick
than I expected
it maybe a little bit out there for some
but if you go along with the ride and
open your mind a little bit then you'll
have a great time
la-la-land is by director Damien
Chazelle and he's the same guy who is
behind whiplash similar to that film
this one also deals with ambition and
jazz music but the tone is completely
different this stars Ryan Gosling and
Emma Stone in their third collaboration
together and they have wonderful
chemistry he's an aspiring jazz musician
she's an aspiring actress and they're
both trying to make it together and
apart in the crazy City of LA there's so
much that I can't see
it is just so joyful and so much fun to
watch the production design is wonderful
I wanted to watch this movie again I
wanted to study it frame by frame I
wanted to live inside it and finally
lion starring Dev Patel the movie that
got me right in the field
[Music]
I have to find my way back home this is
based on a true story about a young
Indian boy called Sioux who lost his
family in Calcutta and ended up being
adopted by an Australian family played
by the always brilliant Nicole Kidman
and the equally excellent David Wenham
years later the grown ups Arun now
played by Dev Patel becomes obsessed
with the idea of trying to find his
family which of course is kind of like
finding a needle in a haystack
Rooney Mara also stars as soos
girlfriend
I loved this movie it is so emotional
and just gorgeous the way that it's all
put together the way that it comes
together
directed by Garth Davis and Dev Patel is
wonderful special shout out also to Tom
Ford's nocturnal animals which is really
trippy but interesting and also Jay a by
owners a monster Paul's
which will definitely make you cry
and that's it for the first episode of
fandango's indie movie guide I hope you
enjoyed it let me know in the comments
below which movies you're the most
excited about seeing and you can check
to me anytime on twitter at Alicia
Malone I'll see you soon
[Music]